part of what we're looking at as Trump's
strength his resilience is really a
reflection of Biden's uh fragility
here's a little mainstream media uh this
is CNN's van Jones and Van Jones who is
like again one of these people it's like
you're sometimes right about stuff
you're not completely insane uh but well
I won't even cover it anymore you go
take I do think that what David's
pointing to is is important part of what
we're looking at as Trump's strength his
resilience is really a reflection of
Biden's uh fragility uh Republicans are
not afraid of Joe Biden They're Not
Afraid uh they they don't think that by
putting up somebody this damage frankly
this deranged with this many deficits is
going to hurt them at all because the
polls show over and over again that even
with 978 felonies he's still neck and
neck with Biden and so it's it's it's a
worrying sign you're correct there's
some worrying signs for for Trump there
should be worrying signs for Democrats
that they're not afraid they're not
afraid
of okay so the reason I wanted to show
you that is there's something sayane
there coming out of what van Jones is
saying now you you can make the argument
either way that Trump looks weak or Not
by avoiding Nikki in the debates and
whether it was it was clearly a good
strategy it was a good political
strategy maybe not good for the country
or good for democracy that he didn't
debate the entire time because of course
having him up there defending his ideas
you'd like to believe that the president
can do that but I can't deny that he is
the the presumed nominee at this point
so strategically it did work what he
says at the end there I think is is more
insightful which is that partly what is
fueling Trump it's it's all the okay
you've called us all racists and you
want to chop all the kids wangs off and
he's Trump has seen as the the Bull
workk against that but it's also that oh
it's a freaking it's Joe freaking Biden
let's just do the thing that we did last
time let's just do it again and maybe
from a republican perspective maybe
there will be a different outcome if the
Democrats were running somebody that was
younger and trimmer and could speak
clearly and all of those things and
people actually believed he was the
driving force behind the office of the
presidency there would be a stronger
argument against Donald Trump right
because you'd be like oh well now
actually Trump is 77 he did lose last
time some of the craziness the court
cases blah blah blah but this time it's
like the Republicans basically are
coalescing around him for for many good
reasons but one of the other ex uh extra
reasons let's say is that it's against
Biden so what the hell is the
difference